>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Juan Manuel Perez: The
topic of today is a topic
that has been largely forgotten.
When we think of Spaniards in the
U.S., the first thing that comes
to mind are the Conquerors and
the explorers of the 16th century,
17th century and even 18th century,
but contemporary Spanish immigration
to the U.S. has been
largely forgotten.
And, except maybe for the work by
Herman Breda [phonetic] in 1992,
published by the Murphy Foundation.
It is a subject that is,
you know, basically unknown.
That's why, when I was
contacted this spring and told
about the research that our
speaker today has been doing
for the last 7 years, I got
real excited because, obviously,
immigration is, for obvious
reasons, is of interest
to me since I am an immigrant.
I was born and raised in Spain.
Professor Fernandez is
professor of Spanish History
and Literature at New
York University.
He received his BA from Dartmouth
College in 1983 and his MA and PhD
in Romance Languages in Literature
from Princeton University in 1988.
He taught at Yale University
from 1988 to 1995 before moving
to New York University where
he has been ever since.
At NYU, he served for 12 years
as the Inaugural Director
of University's King Juan
Carlos Center of Spain.
He is author or editor
of several books
on Spanish literature,
history and culture.
And, for the last 7
years, he has been working
on a major project aimed
at documenting the history
of Spanish immigration to the
United States in the late 19th
and early 20th centuries.
Together with Luis Argeo in
2014, he coauthored the book
that he will talk to us about
today, "Invisible Immigrants:
Spaniards in the U.S. 1868-1945".
Professor.
[ Applause ]
>> James D. Fernandez: Thank
you so much, Juan Manuel.
I'd like to express, or repeat, the
expressions of gratitude to everyone
who has made this event possible,
the Library of Congress, Mariel,
Catalina and Juan Manuel Perez.
I'd also like to acknowledge the
support of the Consul General
of Spain in Washington
who's not here yet.
I think he might be on his way,
but Enrique Sarda Valls has been
very supportive of this project
and I'd like to recognize that.
And, also, thank Maria
Molina Alvarez de Toledo,
recently appointed cultural head
of the Embassy's cultural
office, for joining us today.
Thank you so much.
Many of you have been supporting
this project over the years.
And, actually, I've had
the incredible privilege
of just meeting, today
here, some people that,
over the last few years, have been
sending photographs and information
and even money [laughter] to
support, to support this project.
And it really is, it's a
pleasure and an honor to be here.
It's kind of daunting to be
in the Library of Congress
and it's daunting, also, to
start meeting old friends,
or seeing old friends
and meeting new friends,
some of which have been Facebook
friends for several years.
So, thank you all,
really, for being here
and for your support
of this project.
I'm going to begin
by invoking a speech
that might seem very
familiar to many of you.
In the midst of a profound
economic and social crisis,
an aspiring politician
attacks the immigrants
of a certain nation portraying
that nation as a lawless mess
and accusing that nation's
government
of intentionally sending its
most undesirable citizens
to the United States.
Sound familiar?
[Laughter] They are not
sending us their best.
But the speech that I'm
thinking of might sound familiar,
but I don't think any of you
have ever heard it before.
Because the discourse that I'm
referencing was delivered just a few
steps from here, was delivered just
a few steps from here on the Floor
of the House of Representatives
in 1920.
The speaker was Congressman Harold
Knutson, Republican of Minnesota,
and his exact words were these.
Spain is a seething mess of anarchy
and the Spanish government
is gathering these anarchists
and dumping them on
us, 1920 on the Floor
of the House of Representatives.
In the speech, this Norwegian born
Congressman Knutson [laughter] talks
about having recently visited
Ellis Island where he claims
to have witnessed the arrival on
a single day of 2,000 Spaniards.
It is in the face of this perceived
invasion that Knutson and many
of his colleagues,
anti-immigrant colleagues,
proposed the construction, not of
a physical wall, but of a legal,
statistical obstacle, a funnel.
And, within a few years, the
United States would enact a series
of very strict national quotas
limiting the immigration of many,
especially Asians, but also
Southern and Eastern Europeans.
So, by 1924, the annual
quota for Spaniards
who could legally enter
the United States was 131
from the whole country,
for the whole year.
See if I can talk and
chew gum at the same time.
I cite this example of -- unpleasant
example of Hispanophobia directed,
in this case, against, specifically
against Spaniards from 100 years ago
because I think it will surprise
many of you that citizens
of Spain were generating such
anxiety among anti-immigrant folks
like the good Congressman from
Minnesota, or not so good.
It tends to surprise because
very few people know that,
in the last decades of the 19th and
early decades of the 20th century,
tens of thousands of
Spaniards ended up settling
in tightly knit enclaves all over
the United States from Tampa,
Florida to Boise, Idaho,
from Sacramento,
California to Barre, Vermont.
As Juan Manuel said, I've made these
invisible immigrants the subject
of my research for the last 7
or 8 years, and I'd like, today,
to briefly present some of
the findings of this work.
Spaniards in the Americas, Juan
Manuel also alluded to this already,
for many people in the U.S. and
probably for many people in Spain
as well, this phrase,
Spaniards in the Americas,
almost certainly will evoke images
of the Conquistadores, explorers
and friars who, in the name of the
Spanish crown, mapped, explored,
conquered and settled vast swaths
of the Americas, south, central
and north during the 16th, 17th
and 18th centuries, including,
of course, very large portions
of the territory that, today,
forms part of the United States.
Very few people realize, however,
that the number of Spaniards
who left the Iberian Peninsula
to come to the Americas
in the latter half of the 19th
century and the first decades
of the 20, is vastly greater than
the number of all of the Spaniards
who made that same trip in
the previous 4 centuries.
Now think about that.
You can add up -- if we add up the
Spaniards who came to the Americas
between 1850 and 1930, the estimate
made by historians is 4 million.
Four million Spaniards in that 80
year period came to the Americas,
whereas, between Columbus's
first voyage in 1850,
we're talking about
a different scale,
hundreds of thousands,
and not millions.
So the implications of this are
that the massive demographic,
cultural presence of Spaniards
in the Americas is really a 19th
and 20th century phenomenon.
And, when we start thinking this
way, pretty much everything changes.
Here's Consul General Enrique,
thank you so much for joining us.
>> Enrique Sarda Valls:
Sorry to be late.
>> James D. Fernandez:
No, I hope you'll -- .
>> Enrique Sarda Valls: -- I'm sorry
to be late, ladies and gentlemen,
but I wasn't, I couldn't find
the right building [laughter].
So I prayed, I apologize.
>> James D. Fernandez:
Thank you so much.
>> Enrique Sarda Valls: Go on.
>> James D. Fernandez: Thank you.
Yeah, so the implications of this
statistic, right, are that --
and it should, I think it
should change the way we think
about the history of Spain,
the history of Spain's
presence in the Americas.
The massive presence of Spaniards
on these continents is a modern,
almost contemporary phenomenon.
And it occurs mainly after
Spain has lost sovereignty
over most of the Americas.
Those millions of Spaniards are
traveling, for the most part,
to countries that have achieved
their independence from Spain
with the exception, of
course, of Cuba and Puerto Rico
which also continue to receive
massive number of immigrants
through the late 19th century.
But a lot of people don't
know that immigration to Cuba
from Spain actually accelerated
and intensified after 1898, okay.
It seems like a paradox, but we can
talk about that, and it's actually,
it can be explained, okay?
It's in the context of the
waning of the Spanish Empire
in the American Hemisphere and
the emergence of the United States
as an interventionist
imperialist world power
in this late 19th,
early 20th century.
And, especially here in what came to
be called the American Hemisphere,
it's that context, it's
within that context
that roughly 4 million
Spaniards came to the Americas.
And, of course as we know, the vast
majority of those Spaniards went
to Spanish speaking
countries for obvious reasons,
cultural, linguistic affinity.
But a significant number of them
ended up in the United States.
Did that work?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Okay, it's the same picture I think.
So, for several years, I've been
working with Luis Argeo, a writer
and filmmaker from Asturias.
We have been crisscrossing the U.S.
and Spain interviewing
the descendants
of these intrepid immigrants,
filming their oral histories and,
whenever possible, scanning
their family albums.
Our long term goal
is to create a vast,
digital online archive available
to anyone, historians or families,
or anyone interested in this little
known chapter of the shared history
of Spain and the U.S. Along the
way, as we build this archive,
we're producing documentary
films, we've completed 2,
online exhibitions and physical
exhibitions and, also, books.
The first book is the
one I'd like to talk
about today, "Invisible Immigrants".
It was just over a year ago
that we realized, Luis and I,
that we had already
amassed an archive of more
than 7,000 photographs, most
of them never seen beyond
the immediate context
of the family that owned them.
And we realized that those
photos are an invaluable resource
for the reconstruction
of this history,
and decided that the time had come
to try to tell the general story
of this diaspora through
those photographs.
And the book is the
product of that decision.
So this is the map that
we developed as part
of the project of developing
the book.
We've marked enclaves where
we've either conducted research,
or intend to conduct research.
It's not complete.
The book has been out for,
I guess, 6 or 8 months now.
We've already got lots of angry
E-mails saying, "Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania's not
on there" [laughter]
and so we'll be adding to it.
But, in general terms,
I have, you know,
I'm going to give you
a very quick overview
of the diaspora and of the book.
In general terms, we can
think that the Spaniards
who came here either came via
formal recruitment efforts
where an American company would
actually go to Spain and put
up signs and actively
recruit Spanish laborers
for specific industry or task.
And then, what's more common, are
more informal networks that develop.
This is typical in Spanish
immigration to Latin America
as well, these informal networks of
families and towns and industries
and sectors of the economy develop
where countrymen from one part
of Spain settle themselves in
a certain place and involved
in a certain sector of the economy.
And they start bringing cousins
and nephews and uncles and such.
So there are formal
arrangements, formal recruitment,
and a lot of informal networking.
In terms of the formal
arrangements, by far, the largest
and most interesting and
bizarre episode in the history
of Spanish immigration to the U.S.
occurred between 1907 and 1913
when the Hawaiian sugarcane
planters association wanted
to recruit white workers to work
on the sugarcane plantations
of the Hawaiian Islands.
And they started this vast campaign
of recruiting, they recruited many,
the recruited many
people from Puerto Rico.
They recruited many, probably
the largest number from Portugal.
But, for this 6 year period
between 1907 and 1913,
they also concentrated on southern
Spain where, in the provinces
of Malaga and Granada,
they've been growing sugarcane
for over a thousand years.
The sugarcane planters
in Hawaii knew this.
Remember, the United States
took over Hawaii in 1898 and so,
we're in 1907, there's
explicit attempt to whiten
and improve the gene stock
of the Hawaiian Islands
by recruiting white
European workers.
And so the planters look
around the globe and see
where are there white folk that
know how to work with sugarcane,
and the Madeira, the Azores,
Southern Spain and
the Caribbean also.
Within 6 years, they recruited
8,000 Spaniards to make the more
than 50 day voyage to Hawaii from
-- the first ship left from Malaga,
the next 6 left from Gibraltar.
Remember, the Panama
Canal was not open yet,
it was actually being
constructed, so it was a journey
across the Atlantic
around South America
into the Pacific and up to Hawaii.
Eight thousand Spaniards took
that journey and, roughly,
two-thirds of them,
within a few years,
realized that Hawaii was not
what they were looking for.
And they were not satisfied
with the conditions
and made a quick second
emigration to California
where they settled
around Sacramento.
And many of the dots that you
see there correspond to enclaves
of Spaniards who are
actually rebounding
from the Hawaiian Islands.
And they work predominantly
in agriculture, in fruit
and nut harvesting and also
in fishing and fish canneries.
So that's sort of the
biggest and clearest example
of direct, active recruiting.
Most of the other examples
are less direct.
But I'll point out, because we
have some members in the audience
from Tampa, Tampa, Florida became a
crucial enclave of Spaniards vast.
By far, if we want to find
a place in the United States
where this history that I'm talking
about has left a visible trace,
Tampa, Florida is the
place we need to go.
In 1886, a Valencian born cigar
maker, Vicente Martinez Ybor,
decided to move his cigar
making center from Key West,
where he had moved in
1869, that's another story.
The book has the date 1868 in there,
if I had more time, I'd
explain why that is.
In any case, Tampa, Florida becomes
the center of the cigar trade,
Cuban cigar trade, in 1886.
And, within a few decades
-- I should point out,
Tampa had a population
of 700 in 1886
when Vicente Martinez Ybor opened
his factory in the part of --
now part of Tampa called Ybor City.
Within a couple of decades, it
had a population of over 100,000.
And, at its peak, Tampa had more
than 200 cigar factories and turned
out a million cigars a day.
It was the capital of cigar
production in the world.
And the owners of most
of those factories were
from Spain, Spanish born.
Many of the workers were Spanish
born, there were also a lot
of Cuban cigar makers, but the
owners of the factories were,
for the most part, immigrants
themselves from Spain.
So that's the story of Tampa.
The presence of Spaniards in
Tampa got so big that, of course,
many Spaniards could make livings
having restaurants and cafes
and dairies catering to
the Spaniards, all right.
It was a community so large
that it generated a diverse
economy of Spaniards.
Something similar happens in the New
York area, whereas, in California,
we can say almost all of the
immigrants devoted themselves
to agriculture and fishing.
In the case of New York and
Tampa, to a certain extent,
where the economy was very diverse,
we have Spaniards in
all walks of life.
Entertainment, food, hardly
anyone knows this, but the founder
of Goya Foods which most Americans
associate with its consumers
which are largely not
Spanish, but the founder
of Goya Foods was from Burgos.
Prudencio Unanue was a
Spaniard who formed part
of this same story that I'm telling.
Gregorio Bustelo, you guys drink
-- before there was Starbucks,
the only good coffee you
could get was Café Bustelo,
dark roasted Latin style coffee.
Gregorio Bustelo was
from Galicia, okay?
We associate that brand with
Puerto Ricans and Cubans
who are the main consumers,
and to whom the product has
been marketed the most, okay?
There are lots of dots
in the western mountain states
corresponding mostly to enclaves
of basks who were brought
over to work as shepherds
on the vast ranches and shepherd
ranges of the Montana, Nevada,
Idaho and Washington State.
There's also in the
audience, I just today,
met someone who I've
been corresponding
with for some years now who's
a representative of Spaniards
in the area of St. Louis, Missouri.
And there's a whole archipelago
of enclaves around the center
of the country, most of which have
something to do with metal industry.
Again, I can't go into
the details of the story,
but there was a zinc foundry in
a part of Asturias in the county
of Castile Leon which is actually
where my grandfather is from.
A zinc foundry that
exported thousands of workers
to similar factories
wherever there was zinc.
So Luis and I have learned
this in our research,
if we want to identify
enclaves of Spaniards,
one of the things we can do is to
go to guides of industry and find
out where there was
zinc in, say, 1910.
Wherever there was zinc,
there were Spaniards.
Unlikely places like West Virginia.
There were so many Spanish
workers in West Virginia in 1910
that an honorary Spanish
consulate was set up in Clarksburg,
West Virginia to attend
to the Spanish workers.
So West Virginia, the St. Louis
area on both sides of the river,
many Spanish immigrants,
mostly from Asturias and mostly
from this very region around Arnaud
[phonetic] right near Aviles,
Consejo de Castilla y Leon.
So all those dots in Donora,
Pennsylvania, Spelter,
West Virginia, Kent in
Ohio, those all correspond
to what we call the zinc circuit.
So just to give a rough idea of
where these, how this map was made
and where these folks settled.
So the book, we analyzed the oral
histories that we had collected,
and we looked over this vast archive
of images, and came up with a story
that it's not any one
immigrant's story,
but it's kind of a composite
average story based on all
of the information
that we've gathered.
And we created 6 chapters in the
book, each chapter corresponded
to one of the sentences
of the story, which,
as you can see, is very simple.
In time of great upheavals among
millions of other immigrants,
they were but a drop in the bucket.
In chapter 1, contains photographs
that we scanned from family albums
of life in Spain prior,
immediately prior to the departure
and also the kinds of images
that the immigrants brought
with them from Spain.
They arrived and spread
out all over the country
in search of opportunities.
Chapter 2 is devoted to work,
the kinds of work that they did
and the photographs that
they made of their work.
Chapter 3, together
they laughed and cried,
together they lived and loved.
This is the longest chapter of the
book that looks at social customs,
leisure time, cultural
activities, courtship, marriage,
children and the fabric of life.
Chapter 4 is about the organizations
that the Spaniards formed,
I'll talk a little bit about
that when we get to that chapter.
But they formed vast networks
of very diverse organizations
to take care of each other.
Chapter 5, they got organized and
rallied behind a cause that lost.
The impact of the Spanish Civil War
on this community cannot
be underestimated,
and it played a crucial role in
the kinds of decisions they made
about where they were from and
where they wanted to be from.
And, finally, they were here
to stay, the last chapter,
contains images of assimilation,
those images of becoming
permanently American.
So chapter 1, we have lots
of photographs like this one
which is a picture
of those left behind.
Many family albums
contain photographs
of the loved ones who
didn't emigrate.
This is a family in Alicante in
the village of Casas del Senor.
And these are the folks
who didn't come, okay.
It's from an album in
Monterey, California.
The relatives of these folks went to
Hawaii and ended up in California.
The grandson of these folks would
become the Mayor of Monterey,
California and serve for
20 years as the Mayor
of Monterey from 1986 to 2006.
Our first documentary film is
a portrait of Daniel Albert
in his original Valenciano name,
Dan Albert in perfect English
[laughter], an amazing character.
Let's see, this is the house that
those people lived in in Alicante.
This is a typical portrait of
immigrant on the eve of immigration.
This is from Lugo.
Jose Vasquez was about
to leave for Cuba.
We'll see him later in New York
in front of his clothes store.
The family saved many documents,
including this incredible poster
that was put up all
over southern Spain.
This is a scan of an original poster
promising [inaudible] to Spaniards
who were willing to get on
the ship and go to Hawaii.
It lays out the conditions
and describes Hawaii
in these terms of paradise.
Also, a lot of pictures in family
albums are, as I said before,
like relics from the old country.
These 2 pictures are, especially
interesting because, on the left,
is Juan Sanchez Aricon
[phonetic] of Cadiz,
of San Roque in his army outfit
which he wore when he was sent
to fight in the Spanish
American War in 1896.
And we see the same Juan
Sanchez Aricon on the right
at a photographic studio at La
Limia shortly before embarking,
once again to cross the Atlantic,
but this time to continue
on to the Pacific and become a sugar
cane worker on the Hawaiian islands.
He'd serve in the army
of the country
that he fought against
in World War I.
And it's not that uncommon.
These folks, they were in the
Spanish American War fighting
for Spain in the late
1800s and drafted to fight
in the U.S. Army in World War I.
The descendants of this
photograph are in the audience.
I've just met them.
This is a portrait of Santa Maria
del Mar in the county of Castrillon.
This is the Fernandez
Menendez family,
the entire family emigrated
to the Saint Louis area.
And this is the typical, kind
of portrait on the vispera,
the eve of departure,
kind of documenting this is what
we look like just before we go.
The second chapter, they arrived
and spread out all over the country
in search of opportunities.
This is a group of Galician
immigrants aboard the ship
that brought them, Ocupania
[phonetic] in the family album
of Valego [phonetic]
in Newark, New Jersey.
This is the exploration
of their places of work.
We realized, as we did this chapter,
that there are some work places
where you don't take your camera.
So people that worked inside
mines or digging tunnels
or in the engine room of a ship
which are vast amounts of Spaniards,
those are very typical occupation,
we don't really have
photographs of that.
Whereas, we have a preponderance of
photos of Spaniards proudly standing
in front of their businesses.
So the small business person,
the guy who owned a cigar factory
or a hardware store or a boarding
house or a café, we have many,
many beautiful pictures
of that genre.
But we should keep in mind that a
lot of these folks were in places
where cameras didn't go, okay.
Documents like passports or visas,
like this one, here's a picture
of -- I'm sorry, that's
a passport I guess, yeah.
This is a photograph
of Tampa cigar workers
at a boarding house in Ybor City.
These are recently arrived
immigrants from Galicia,
from Sava in the province of A
Coruna on the house of the tenement
where they lived on
the Lower East Side
with the Manhattan
Bridge in the background.
Again, this photograph which looks
like it should be in a museum is
in the family album of the Sanchez
Alonso family in Astoria Queens.
And, like this, hundreds
of documents
that we're doing everything
we can to preserve.
These are, this is the staff
of a legendary Basque hotel
in the West Village,
Valentina Gira, crucial figure
in the history of Spanish
immigration.
Valentina Gira had several sons,
he'd send them to the docks.
When the ships bearing Spaniards
would come in, they would shout
in Basque and in Spanish
[foreign language spoken], oh,
if you follow me, all Basques
and Spaniards, he'd take them
to 82 Bank Street where they'd
get a room and a meal and advice
about where to find work, very often
in those sheep ranches
out in the west.
Valentina Gira was in constant
contact with his Basque compatriots.
He had a vast network, and he worked
basically an employment agency
out of this location.
The building still stands
in the West Village.
Here's that same fellow
we saw before,
Jose Vasquez on the
eve of his departure.
He was in Cuba for some
years, then came to New York,
ended up owning a woman's
clothing store on 14th Street
which was the heart
of a neighborhood once called
Little Spain, La Vernia [phonetic].
A grocery store in West Tampa
which had rooms above it
for single cigar workers,
bachelor cigar workers.
This is a factory crew at the zinc
foundry in Spelter, West Virginia.
The Basque Hotel in San Francisco,
I'm pretty sure this is prior
to the great earthquake.
I think this hotel
burned down in 1906.
Migrant Spanish farmworkers
near Vacaville in California,
notice the tents in the
background, these Spaniards traveled
around like many people do today,
many Spanish speaking
people do today
in California still, mostly Mexican.
Traveling up and down the
California Valley based on the cycle
of the harvest of the crops.
There were Spaniards doing
this in the '20s and '30s.
And here's a group of Spanish
children and those tents are
where they would sleep
in harvest season.
Uh-oh. Okay, I don't
know what happened there.
That's okay.
This is a very moving picture of
the burial of a cannery worker
in Monterey, California,
a young Spaniard who died
in an industrial accident.
Next chapter, living la vida,
in Spanglish, because that sort
of started becoming the
language spoken by this community
as they had children and adapted
to life in the United States.
Chapter devoted to, as I said
before, leisure, fun, courtship,
marriage, things like that.
Again, beautiful photographs.
The beach, this is
Rye Beach, New York,
bunch of Asturian girls [laughter].
It was very common to take
these kind of gag photographs,
especially a newly arrived
Spanish immigrant would think,
oh what a joke, I'm driving a car.
It was like it was so outlandish,
especially if they sent this back
to the village, that it was funny.
But the remarkable thing
is that 3 or 5 years later,
they'll be sending back photos
of them actually driving cars.
But, yeah, right now it's a gag.
Many beautiful studio
portraits often taken
to send back to the relatives.
This is a pool room in Ybor
City, not a place you'd want
to get caught late at night,
if you're not from Ybor City.
This is a gorgeous photograph,
it looks like Asturias.
The Asturian born Angel Alonso
[phonetic] who lost his job
in New York during the Depression,
and went back to doing what he knew
how to do best which was farming.
He moved to upstate New York and
rented a farm and grew apples
and made hay and had cows and
he's in Walk Hill, New York,
and it looks like he's
back in Navares Asturias
which was his hometown
near Arriondas.
His children were born in New
York and Manuel is still alive,
one of my main informants,
the fellow on the right.
He's 95. That farm that they
set up became, eventually,
a kind of boarding house, a
hotel, where they would take
in other Spanish families in the
summer months who were trying
to get away from the
heat of the city
and eat some fresh
food and speak Spanish.
My family's actually
in this photograph,
my father's the little boy in
the very center of the picture,
because his family would
occasionally spend a week there
in the summer, again, to get out
of the sweltering heat of the city.
It's so moving to find photographs
of one family in the album
of another family, but it's
happening to us more and more.
So I was looking through the
photographs of the Alonso family
and came across this
photo of my grandfather
and grandmother and parents.
Some photographs, like this,
have almost allegorical value
because this is a family
of Sevillanos who went
to Hawaii and then to California.
And it's almost as if their stringed
instruments were allegorically
telling the story [laughter].
They've got the Spanish
guitar, the Hawaiian ukulele
and the American banjo [laughter].
The next chapter is about the
organizations that they formed.
Like all other immigrants who came
to the U.S. before the New Deal,
the Spaniards landed in a country
where there was no safety net,
no ready-made welfare state,
there was no social security,
no unemployment insurance,
no medical insurance.
And these Spaniards all over the
U.S. responded to this situation
with an astounding spirit of
entrepreneurship and solidarity,
forming all manners of
clubs and organizations
to help them care for one another.
So this is a picnic,
this is one-fourth
of a vast panoramic picture
of the Spanish community
in Cleveland, Ohio, 1930.
Another Saint Louis picture, this is
the -- the building still exists --
this is the Sociedad Espanola
of Saint Louis, Missouri.
They brought with them a game,
El Hoyo Del La Jave [phonetic]
which many Spaniards probably don't
know because it's very peculiar
to the area of Asturias
where they're from.
But the guy in the front
is holding this pole
with these aspas [phonetic]
and the game consisted
of throwing these metal discs
from a certain distance and trying
to hit those blades on that stick.
There's still a league of La Jave
in Saint Louis, I've been told,
and you can still go there and play
and probably gamble, I would guess.
Canton, Ohio, I mentioned it before,
had a very active social club.
And Canton is unusual because, as I
mentioned before, one of the streams
of immigrants are the Asturianos
who come following the zinc circuit.
The other stream are on
the [inaudible] who come
from the Rio Tinto, Rio Tinto mines
in the province of
Nuerva [phonetic].
There's a lot of labor unrest and
people are being laid off their jobs
in the teens and into the twenties.
And there's a mini diaspara of
[inaudible] from the province
of Huelva to Canton where
they mix with the Spaniards.
And so their annual picnics have
both flamenco guitar and gaita.
And we've documented cases
of Asturian boys who learned
to become flamenco musicians
because of this mingling,
something that is not likely
to happen on the peninsula.
This is the Centro Vasco
Americano in New York.
The picture's taken
in the club's fronton.
They had an indoor handball
jai alai court from 1930.
Soccer teams, again from
Saint Louis, [inaudible] 1934.
And in other places
like Tampa, Florida,
where there was more
contact with the Cuban world,
baseball took precedence over soccer
and baseball was bigger
in Tampa than soccer.
And the Centro Asturiano
had its own ball team.
Some very famous professional
baseball players
of Spanish descent emerged.
I'll mention a couple
in my conclusion.
Families conserved
a lot of documents,
like this membership
book, actually a dues book
from the Union Benefica
Espanola De Hollister California.
This is the Majestic Theater
of Tampa's Centro Asturiano
which still stands.
I think there's 1400
seats in that auditorium.
It hosted artists like Enrico
Caruso and other greats.
It was, for many years, one of
the best venues in all of Florida,
in terms of its acoustics
for music and theater.
And this is a celebration, or the --
it's a meeting commemorating the
6 months of a workers' strike,
a cigar workers' strike in 1920.
The Spanish Civil War, by the time
the war breaks out in July of 1936,
the colonies of Spanish immigrants
all over the United States are
at their peak in terms of
numbers and cohesiveness.
So they've been arriving
steadily from 1898 to 1920, 22,
when those quota laws
are put in place
and it becomes much
harder to get in.
But they still get, continue to
get it in, lest everyone think
that they were all legal, uh-unh.
And, actually, the Cuba,
Tampa entry was a lot easier
than Ellis Island for, after
the quota laws were enacted
for Spaniards.
So the community is at
its highest point in terms
of cohesiveness and numbers.
If you think about it, the
Great Depression forced them
into helping each other.
So those organizations that they
founded, maybe at the beginning,
they were supporting our cultural
organizations but, after 1929,
they become mutual aid
societies or burial societies.
There's a real need for the
community to help each other.
So throughout the early 1930s, those
clubs get stronger and stronger and,
when the war breaks out in
Spain in 1936, the vast majority
of these working class
immigrants were pro-Republican.
And most of their clubs, in
fact, I can't find many examples
of any clubs that were
pro-Insurgents, pro-Franco, right.
So the vast majority of the
immigrants, and almost all
of their organizations, turned their
efforts to the raising supply --
raising support for
the loyalist cause.
And the family albums are
full of these documents.
Stunning pictures like this
on 14th Street, outside of --
it was actually they're picketing
a Spanish business which is proof
that there were Spaniards
who were pro-Franco.
That was Casa Moneo,
a very important grocery
store on 14th Street.
But this is, it looks
like a newspaper picture,
but it's actually -- the person
who showed me this says, "Oh,
that's my Aunt Zazi", so this
is a family picture [laughter].
Fantastic portraits like this one,
[foreign language spoken]
Canton, Ohio, 1937.
Assorted pictures from the
album of a family in New Jersey.
These are children in Tampa,
Florida dressed up like milicianas
with the popular front salute.
A mass meeting in Manhattan's
Center.
A family in Canton, Ohio has
preserved all of the programs,
since the 1930s, of the annual
Spanish Picnic organized
by the Spanish colonies of the area.
In this juxtaposition of
2 of the program covers,
the one on the left is from
1937, and the one on the right is
from 1946, I think this
juxtaposition provides a perfect
illustration of the process I'm
trying to document and describe
in which the Spanish Civil
War marks a point of no return
for the immigrants in the U.S.
The language and the design
of these 2 covers shows that
something catastrophic has occurred
between 1 cover and
the other, right.
From a Spanish speaking community
on the left still looking back
towards Spain, still living in Spain
in some ways, still deeply involved
in the affairs of the old country.
In 9 years, we move to a community
that's English speaking and that,
this very forward looking
American family which seems well
on its way to assimilation.
So I think that this is a perfect
example of how, in our research,
we've learned that the Spanish Civil
War was really the point where most
of these folks realized that,
if they dreamt about going back,
it wasn't going to happen, or it
certainly wasn't going to be easy.
I'll start wrapping up.
They were here to stay.
One of our standard questions,
when we interview the descendants
of immigrants, is, if their
parents or grandparents had come
to the U.S. knowing that they
would permanently stay here,
or if they had come hoping to make
some money and return to Spain.
And our informants, often, respond
with firmness, sometimes mixed
with surprise, almost
annoyance at the question.
Oh, no, they came here because
they wanted to become American.
It's kind of the standard line
that we get from descendants
of immigrants which
is really not true
and has never historically
been true of any immigrant
that ever left any country,
any time in the history
of immigration [laughter].
And those same people who, without
thinking about it, say, "Oh, no,
they came knowing that they would
become Americans", they then start
to tell us stories
and, in some cases,
they share their archives with us.
In many cases, those archives
have letters in Spanish
that they haven't read,
or can't read,
because they don't have Spanish.
And it's always a much
more complicated picture
and there's almost always
a burning desire to,
at some point, go back to Spain.
The Spanish Civil War is what
really kind of shuts that door.
And we find this in
family after family.
It's really only then that
that dream is put aside or,
at least, postponed.
Those same families that say,
"Oh, no, our parents came
to become Americans", then we go
through the archive and we come
across the Certificates
of Naturalization
and it's 1939, 1940, 1941.
And I'm thinking, okay,
your mother came in 1911.
She registered in the Spanish
Consul every year, 1912, 13, 14,
she'd go to San Francisco
to affirm her Spanishness
because she needed the assistance
of the Consulate and because, maybe,
she dreamt of going back to Spain.
All those years, she was
maintaining her Spanish citizenship.
And, only in '39, '40, '41, does she
go and become an American citizen.
I think, maybe, she was
hoping that maybe she would,
someday, go back to Spain.
This is a beautiful Thanksgiving
dinner in San Leandro, California.
These were folks that had
passed through Hawaii.
I love these pictures of
multi-generations where you can see,
almost, the process of assimilation.
The Spanish grandmother in the
dress and the Spanish granddaughter
in the bathing suit, and
the mother kind of in
between these worlds, right.
In some ways, the whole
process is there.
Actually the mother of this picture
was born in the Panama Canal zone.
Her parents were operating
a funda there.
Lovely portraits of these
children assimilating.
That's Dan Albert, Daniel Albert.
Born in 1930, his parents
didn't allow him
to play American sports during
the early years of his life
because they were going
to go back to Spain.
You couldn't play that
barbaric version of football
and get hurt, and not
be able to work.
By 1940, he was trying
out for the football team
and became captain
of the football team.
And had this -- and eventually coach
of the Monterey High
School football team.
And here's his mother's
Naturalization Certificate
from 1940.
Spanish women studying in a kind
of business school in New York.
This fellow, Uncle Bill Castro,
his claim to fame, in the 1930s,
was his castanet playing.
And, in the 1940s, we see
him playing the drums.
So a lovely graduation
picture from Tampa.
And we come back to the
kind of where we started.
This family from Castrillon,
from Santa Maria del Mar,
all of whom immigrated.
I think they had some other
children that also eventually came.
And we jump forward 30 years and
see them here at a family gathering
in 1934 in East Saint Louis.
I don't know if you can see
the patriarchs are still there.
The mother and father here,
here they are 30 years later.
Those children have now had children
and, in 1 case, the baby in the arms
of the matriarch of the family
is the first great grandchild
of this clan who, I've just been
told, is the only person still alive
of everyone in this picture.
So I'll -- in closing, folks
like these and all the people
that we've been looking at, got into
this country just under the wire,
in some ways, in that brief
window of time before Mr. Knutson
and likeminded politicians
stopped the flow
of these dangerous elements that,
according the anti-immigration
lobbies,
Spain and other countries were
dumping on the United States.
The descendants of some of
these folks have become famous,
like the actor, Martin Sheen,
the musician, Jerry Garcia,
all the ballplayers, Al Lopez,
Lou Piniella and Tino Martinez.
But the vast majority, like the bulk
of a massive iceberg, led lives full
of solidarity, sacrifice and dignity
and became fully assimilated and,
therefore, practically invisible
American citizens as teachers,
doctors, homemakers, lawyers,
bakers, politicians, et cetera.
And many of us are among you today.
We've been fortunate enough to be
able to interview many children
of the immigrants who are
now in their 80s and 90s.
They are usually the keepers
of these precious archives
and they are the ones who
possess the keys that we need
to interpret family
documents and photographs.
So, with each passing generation,
information gets a little sketchier
and the photographs get a
little bit closer to being put
in the attic and, God help us, maybe
even someday disposed of, right?
These people won't be
with us much longer
which is what lends real urgency
to this project and to our task
of rescuing the documentary legacy
of Spain's intrepid invisible --
intrepid and invisible immigrants.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Enrique Sarda Valls:
Thank you, James.
I'm going to address you some words,
ladies and gentlemen,
better late than never.
I met James earlier this
year and it was by chance.
We were sitting together at
the [foreign language spoken],
which is a gathering of Spanish
gentlemen and, only male generally,
that will meet regularly every
month at [foreign language spoken]
for chatting over lunch and coffee.
And James was sitting next to me.
I had just arrived
a few months before
in Washington and hardly
knew anyone.
And we start talking about this
and I was so fascinated by it
from the first moment about
his project, that I said,
you must come to the Consulate and
deliver a lecture on the subject.
And, after I learned more about
it, my fascination increased,
particularly when I knew that it
was crowdfunding was the method
to gather the monies to
carry out the project.
And also the thing that to
resort to private family archives
to reconstruct the history
of the Spanish immigration
to this country was a matter
of big, big interest for me.
James held this lecture at the
Consulate in February, I recall,
it was an enormous success.
And ever since, I was so
enthusiastic about his work
that I tried to promote it with my
web pages, with my Facebook and,
when he offered me to come here
today, I immediately accepted.
It's a great pleasure to
be with you and to share
with you this deeply
moving human experience.
As a human, as a Spanish
Consul General,
and 36 years of career behind me,
I had the opportunity of dealing
with a lot of immigrants.
And these photos that we have
seen here today are the photos
that any Spanish family could have
in its album, in their albums.
And my family will
find photos like that,
of course I am already a little
bit rather old, I'm 63 years old.
But they're style of my
childhood, until in Spain
in the 1960s was exactly the one
that we can see on
these photographs.
So it has been, for me, a
very, very moving experience.
It is interesting, at this
point, to make a difference
when what is our immigration
today to the United States
and what was the traditional
immigration.
Today, we have, nowadays, we have
a Spanish brand new immigration
to United States which started
more or less after the first years
of the crisis, the big,
the big crisis in Spain.
And it has nothing to
do with this kind of,
with was our traditional immigration
or which was the immigration
that help Spain to
develop in the '60s.
This was a manpower
immigration, labor.
And the immigration we have
today is what is called,
has been called talent immigration.
And it is fascinating to establish
the difference between these kinds
that translates the progress
and [inaudible] by my country.
I am very, very proud of it and,
because Spain has been contributing
to the United States in the past and
now according to its possibilities.
And when I talk about the
actual, the present immigration
to the United States, I see that
it is the fruit of 2 generations
at least of families that have
done everything for their children,
to provide their children for
a higher degree of education.
And, I must say, to the
United States come the best
of our brains nowaday.
And I don't think that's
[inaudible] that is
to deprive [inaudible]
country of its own talent.
On the contrary, now these
people are going to return,
most of them eventually, to
Spain and they're going to return
with the -- we're going to
return with the experiences
with our networks, with our
contacts, and our new knowledge
and that will enormously enriching
for my country and from Europe.
And I always say that Spain has
a role to play in this country
in the Latin or Hispanic
collective because, myself,
I consider myself here in the United
States like a Latino or Hispanic
from Spain, like someone
would be Latino,
Hispanic from Venezuela or Cuba.
And I think that we have
definitely a role still
to play here in this country.
And I'm very, very optimistic
about what's going on nowadays.
Thank you very much for having
come today and thank you to you,
James, for your admirable work.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.